when I was watching holdovers which you
do this brilliant performance and you
know now you're being recognized by the
Academy Awards I I was like oh [__] Paul
has a really [__] up eye I wonder if
he's okay I never realized it before
like I was like yeah I guess in private
parts his eyes were kind of [__] up or
something like I started imagining that
I had been so narcissistic that I never
even looked at your face and realized
you had a [__] up eye and then I read
some interview with you that you had
done and said yeah the the eye is part
of the character the was the charact I
have a friend of mine that I've known
since I was five I've grown up with the
guy he's one of my best friends and he
said for the first 20 minutes of the
movie he kept thinking have I never
noticed that the poor guy is a [__] up
eye and I thought what a [__] howu
stupid are you of course that's the the
thing in my eye but I I guess it worked
really well which is good because it
could have not and it but it does work
well it thought I thought about it'd be
good maybe if it is a glass eye there
could be some moment where I sneeze or
something in my eye comes comes out and
rolls down the table or you can see my
eye on a glass by my bed or something
like that but I think they thought that
was a step too far the whole time you
did the movie whatever they do to [__]
up your eye I don't know how they do it
like it's a lens it was a it's a big
soft contact lens and it's you know and
there's a guy they have to have a guy
they have to have a guy taken in and out
I couldn't do it myself I can't the only
thing I get squeamish about in life is
stuff around my eyes I can't wear
contact lenses I can't really I mean
glasses I will not wear contact lenses
cuz the idea is something coming out my
eye completely freaks me out so I don't
do it so it was it was took a lot for me
to get used to it going in and out then
I was fine once once it happened but and
could you see normally out of your eye
when they put this no it's just opaque
so I was blind and and one eye I
couldn't see out of one eye and driving
the car that was a nightmare and it was
like trying to pull up to the curb and
they'd be like can you get closer to the
curb I'm like I can't see the [__]
curb I can't give me a break I was like
I can't see anything oh yeah remember
that scene where you're driving the kid
took I couldn't get to the curb I
couldn't see anything but you know and I
felt nervous too have people in the car
with me and stuff like that you know so
I was nervous about it it actually made
me more nervous than practically
anything else I've ever done because of
the eye thing I just was like oh my God
this is going something's going to go
wrong then you're outside in the cold
and they worried it's going to freeze to
my eyeball so the so the GU to keep
putting I mean the whole thing was
bizarre it was it was really
bizarre